[Music]
[Music]
yeah well that's wonderful news she got
a flat tire in Sherwood Forest and she
wants me to go fix it after the official
trailer drops 40 students three we
noticed something important it sure
looks like Len mal will end up being
allies keep watching for all the signs
that these two will end up being friends
again the signs Disney Channel really
had us thinking that uma was going to
team up with Hades to destroy the
barrier in is it uma and uma is back
teasers Lula was talking about how much
she hated mal she thinks mal turned her
back on the Isle of the Lost and all the
decays but we know that's not true the
official trailer that dropped on June
16th 2019 explains a lot more it looks
like villains keep getting through the
barrier and Hades is the most dangerous
one of all a sleeping spell is spreading
through Oregon and Hades ember can stop
it it's the only thing more powerful
than Maleficent sceptre and uma features
pretty heavily in this trailer Disney
Channel wants you to think that she's
one of the bad guys
but there's a ton of signs that she will
turn good they used to be BFFs lest I
forget that Malin uma used to be best
friends when they were younger on the
Isle they were the coolest to BK's
around they were also the toughest but
things changed Malin uma were trying to
prank Carlos's mom relative ill but mal
had ulterior motives she fell into the
water and tricked uma when she least
expected it mal then dumped a bucket of
fresh shrimp on Emma's head it was
totally humiliating to make matters
worse now got everyone to call uma
shrimpie after that they became sworn
enemies but they are older now mal has
grown up a lot since she left the isle
she is mature and she really wanted to
help uma in the second movie she wants
to help all the V Ches we think that
when times get really bad in the third
movie they'll have to forgive each other
it's pretty sad that a little prank
ended their friendship but you can't get
rid of those feelings that you have for
your bestie that easily it's like trying
to wash your hair free of a stinky
shrimp smell it just doesn't go away
overnight they'll realize that it was
just a childish fight and move on at
least we sure hope they will
uma isn't evil uma might be
and she might be the meanest one on the
aisle but she isn't evil the actual
villains like Hades and Maleficent
definitely are not good people but uma
just wanted a better life
she was super jealous that now got to
leave the aisle she just wants a better
life where she isn't forced to live in
isolation and who can blame her life on
the Isle of the Lost isn't easy and all
the vks are paying the price for the
things their parents did when it comes
right down to it
uma is not evil she cares about her
friends and she cares about all the V
K's on the Isle things are getting
really dark in descendents three luma
isn't going to one innocence BK's to get
hurt once she realizes that now really
is fighting for the right to the BK's
she'll come to her senses
the Pirates leave the isle uma and the
Pirates are going to auradon in the new
movie we can see that Harry and Gil jump
through the barrier and that means that
Emma isn't far behind them when she's in
auradon uma will see things for what
they really are mal is working to get
the B Ches off the aisle it's Adam Ben's
dad that is warning her against opening
the barrier over and over plus B Ches
are going to fall victim to the sleeping
spell sneeze kids get cursed biased Smee
who is a pirate so we know that boomer
will feel connected to his twins she'll
want to save them
Oh what is this or did I think they'd
fight together Zuma and the Pirates are
definitely teaming up with mal and the
other vks in the trailer we see a fight
scene in our dime there are a bunch of
knights fighting the V case look closely
at the back uma is standing right next
to mal Harry and Gil are also fighting
alongside even Carlos if they are
fighting a common enemy
Lulla can't be the real villain uma has
the Ember that now means she says that
this is a job for pirates because she
knows they can help Malin uma are also
in the forest together this will
probably be when they decide to team up
now can be pretty convincing but look
what happens when Celia throws the Ember
away mal looks really scared and upset
it definitely looks like uma is just as
worried as now and we think that's
because they are fighting on the same
side uma is mouths only hope at the end
of the trailer now you'll see there are
four people turned into statues
these look like Evy Carlos and J for
sure and the fourth one has probably
been this means that uma and the pie
our mouths only chance for allies these
two will have to unite because they need
each other and once they fight together
they will realize that they aren't
enemies anymore there are more important
things than silly pranks they played as
kids and let's be honest it's a Disney
movie it will have a happy ending since
Malin has been trying to save the vks
she will probably get them all off the
aisle or at least open the barrier
permanently hula will realize that she
was wrong about now and these two will
end up being great friends again thanks
for watching hit that subscribe button
so you never miss another video and
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up we'll catch you next time
[Music]